okay let's go next to our caller from
the six-30 area code who's calling today
from six-30
hi David my name is Clark I'm from in
Algonquin Illinois hey Clark great great
to be on the show I I just got to say
god bless you for what you do and I'm
gonna come right out the door with
connecting with what I just said there
what do you think about the statement
claim proposal from that of someone who
is majimak lee in support of andrew yang
would love a yang VP I'm sorry war yang
President Warren or burn ATP mm-hmm VP I
you know Bernie won yang any of them
I'll say any of them just you know don't
get us stuck with like their there's a
feel I'm not gonna name my amputee but
anyways what do you think about the
suggestion for people like for example
Jesse Lee Peterson all the way to Donald
Trump
so that of people that are left-leaning
and not necessarily believing in the
ideology that's claim to be the
foundation of the Republican Party which
is family values and I would say the
sentiments and values of Christ Jesus
which seems absolutely hip-pocket like
the most hypocritical thing in the world
to anyone that actually spends any time
learning about the teachings and values
Christ what would you say to the
suggestion of why not utilize the Bible
and other I mean really just
interpretation of it but I mean even
just scripture and face value like while
I was listening to the I recently
started listening to you and when I
heard the Jesse Lee Peterson interview I
was like this guy has to be either
completely just the master of trolls or
he truly is like just absolutely
brainwashed and I really kind of think
it's the latter for the majority of the
people but what do you think about that
suggestion because I I mean that's
that's generally what I go to when I get
at it with people that really try to use
the vibe
as rhetoric or as Clark okay hold on I
got it I'm sorry I got to interrupt you
because I don't know what you're talking
about you saying what do I think about
using the Bible to admit to justify
political positions yeah
I'm against it I believe in separation
of church and state and I think no
matter whether you can hold on a second
I I believe that no matter whether you
can make an argument for or against the
policy on the basis of the Bible I don't
think that should have any part in our
sort of national discourse now at the
individual level I have no problem with
in for example an evangelical Christian
community I have no problem if within
that community people want to start
saying hey you know what if we really
want to vote the values of our
congregation
we should be voting for this left-wing
candidate over this right-wing candidate
that's great from the point of view of
the national discourse I don't think
that the Bible should be a factor in how
we make law or policy and for me
personally it's not relevant but for
progressive Christians absolutely go in
and advocate for the Bible actually
suggesting progressive ideas rather than
conservatives I think that that's great
well for for someone as I would just say
as well-informed as yourself that
encounters people that use this I mean
regardless of if you believe in it it's
very frequently utilized as a
counter-argument it is well the Bible is
very often the Bible has stimulated huge
amounts of Republican support on the
basis particularly of the issue of
abortion for a while on the issue of gay
marriage etc so I think fighting fire
with fire is is great it's just not for
me as an individual and I don't think it
should be part of the national debate on
what laws we should or shouldn't have
okay can I just ask one more question
that's not completely different around
that thank you you know I've got 42
people holding so that I think call back
for the next question I really
appreciate your call I do want to get to
somebody else before we run out of time
no problem thank you